[Musique]
ces images de compétition ce sont les
souvenirs auxquels se raccroche mari
cette danseuse de 26 ans a pris le
dernier avion de krasnodar vers la
france depuis elle n'a pas revu nicolaï
son compagnon est partenaire de
compétition c'était le 2 avril dernier
et juridiquement aux yeux de la loi on
est des parfaits inconnus l'un pour
l'autre chose qui n'est absolument pas
le cas dans la réalité en tant que
couples binationaux on nous demande de
présenter des factures eau donnant août
et bayod donnons des conjoints ce genre
de documents donc ils prouvent entre
parenthèse d'une vie commune mais un
amour à distance
c'est pas comme ça que ça se passe du
tout généralement on s'organise pour se
retrouver soi chez l'un soit chez
l'autre ça veut dire qu'on a chacun
notre chez soi ou alors dans des pays
tiers donc on part en vacances ensemble
ou voilà il ya beaucoup de personnes qui
ont repris leur vie normale le 11 mai
quand il ya eu des confinement tout le
monde est retourné au retourner au
travail
tournon a revu ses amis même en petit
comité même en prenant des mesures de
sécurité mais pour nous notre vie
normale elle a pas repris en fait on est
dans l'attenté et se passe rien donc
pour le moment c'est c'est toujours de
la souffrance
en attendant les deux danseurs ont
trouvé un autre rythme
plusieurs fois par jour ils communiquent
par appels vidéo moi ça va faire comme
eux plus de 70 couples franco russes
sont séparés par la pandémie selon les
chiffres récoltés par la députée la
république en marche
anne je ne t'ai 700 couples binationaux
attendent de pouvoir se retrouver pour
accélérer la cadence
marie et nicolas y ont relayé sur les
réseaux sociaux la pétition
internationale
love is not tourisme à ce jour elle a
recueilli plus de 26 mille signatures
elle peut tenir un très grand nombre de
personnes
elle montre que les gens sont prêts à
crier leur amour à s'unir et à prouver
le droit à l'existence de ces couples
ensemble
mystère elle force les gouvernements de
différents pays à réfléchir au fait
qu'une relation entre un homme et une
femme
même si elle est informel et nettes
enregistrées par a le droit d'exister et
doit être prise en compte vendredi
dernier des représentants du mouvement
ont été reçus au ministère des affaires
étrangères d'après jean baptiste lemoyne
secrétaire d'état chargé du tourisme des
français de l'étranger et de la
francophonie
une solution pourrait être trouvée dans
les prochains jours la crise sanitaire à
séparer des couples suite à la fermeture
de frontières
les équipes france diplomatie et du
ministère de l'intérieur travaille avec
le collectif love is not tourisme qui
portent légitimement ce sujet douloureux
une solution dédiée sera mise en place
dans les tout prochains jours
un espoir pour marie et nikolay de se
retrouver mais aussi de reprendre la
compétition ensemble quand on habite ici
tous les deux au niveau de la danse on
s'entraînait quotidiennement points et
des cours aussi trois quatre fois par
semaine avec nos professeurs ça
représente entre 4 et 6 heures de danse
par jour plus le week-end on partait en
compétition soit à l'étranger en russie
où pour l'envié aussi en france de temps
en temps quand il y avait donc on est
vraiment habitué à être ensemble 24
heures sur 24 et à partager notre
passion ensemble en plus de notre vie de
couple
tac du jour au lendemain d'être séparée
bas de son compagnon mais de sa passion
et de son travail en même temps ça fait
beaucoup d'un dans la tante marie valse
entre les démarches auprès des autorités
et les travaux de son école de danse
qu'elle inaugurera à guérande le 17 août
prochain
d'ici là elle espère que nicolas y aura
pu la retrouver pour fouler ce nouveau
parc est ensemble